hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to do an
experiment looking at density
remember that density is calculated as
mass divided by volume so basically the
amount of mass that an object has per
unit of its volume we are going today to
do an experiment looking at the density
of soda using a can of regular coca-cola
and using a can of Diet over Cola
we will submerge them in a tank of water
to see if they are more or less dense
than water if more dense they should
sink to the bottom of the container if
less dense
they should look let's see what happens
so we just saw that putting a can of
coke and a can of Diet Coke into water
you see different effects the coca-cola
sinks diet coke can floats why is this
remember that density is a measure of
mass per unit of volume therefore it
we're seeing different densities they
must have some kind of difference in
these characteristics if we look at the
coke cans
it says 355 milliliters this one also
says 355 milliliters so you can see that
they're the same volume
perhaps it's a different end mass that
is leading to the defensive in density
let's look at their masses real quick
now that we know their mass and their
volume we can calculate their density or
cope with a massive 380 grams and a
volume of 355 milliliters that works out
to 1.08 grams per milliliter their diet
coat we saw that its mass is a little
lower 370 grams divided by 355
milliliters use the density of 1.04
grams per milliliter so we see here that
their densities are different because of
that difference in mass the heavier
density of coke is such that it will
sink to the very bottom of a container
of water of course water density is one
point zero zero grams per milliliter
diet coke on the other hand has a lower
mass therefore a lower density even
though it has the same volume as regular
coke
it's been to be 1.0 four grams per
milliliter is still slightly heavier
than water which is why we see the diet
coat hovering just under the surface of
the water but it's not so much that it
stinks to the very bottom like we see
with regular and of coke now let's
briefly talk about these matches why are
they so different it's the same amount
and volume of liquid why is regular
coca-cola heavier well it is because of
the sugar regular coke has a lot more
sugar whereas Diet Coke just has a
little bit of artificial sweetener and
that is the reason for their different
densities that's it for today I hope you
found it interesting learning about how
regular coke is more dense than Diet
Coke